[موسيقى]
تراجع المؤشرات ام مؤشرات التراجع الجهاز
المركزي للتعبئه العامه والاحصاء وشاهد من
اهل النظام وجهه حكوميه شك في ولائها نشر
تقريرا صادما يكشف كيف ان البوصله
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وفي ميادين حيويه
كالصحف والتعليم والزراعه لا تبعث على
الاطمئنان ما يدعو للتساؤل اين ذهبت عشرات
المليارات التي حصل عليها نظام السيسي
واين الوعود التي قطعها الرجل على نفسه
احن اول وعد معاكم قلت لكم اصبروا معايا
سنتين قلت اصبروا معايا ايه سنتين سنتين
صبروا لكن النظام لم يفي بعشرات الوعود
التي قطعها على نفسه في خطاباته التطمين
منذ انقلاب يوليو عام
2013 ذاك ما اظهرته ارقام حكوميه رسميه
مصريه لا تقارير دوليه او بيانات من قبل
معارضيه الجهاز المركزي للتعبئه العامه
والاحصاء يصدر تقريرا صادما ما الت اليه
الاحوال في عموم القطاعات في مصر اذ كشف
تراجعا حادا في المؤشرات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
والديمغرافي التقرير الذي يحمل اسم مصر في
ارقام ونقلته وسائل الاعلام المحليه على
استحياء يفصح عن تدهور كبير في مجالات
الاقتصاد والخدمات والسياحه والتعليم
والصحه ومعدلات الفقر والبطاله ونسب
الحوادث ففي الجانب الاقتصادي زاد العجز
في الميزان التجاري بنسبه 22 في ما ادى
الى تراجع معدل نمو الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي وبالتوازي انخفضت ايرادات
السياحه خلال عام من 7 مليارات
و371 مليون دولار عام
2014 الى نحو 3 مليارات و700 مليون عام
2015 وذلك بنسبه ناهز
50% اما قناه السويس فقد انخفضت قيمه
ايرادات رسوم المرور منها من 5 مليارات
و362 مليون دولار الى 5 مليارات
و122 مليونا اي بنسبه انخفاض بلغت 4 ونص
في خلال عام واحد كما انخفضت تحويلات
المصريين العاملين في الخارج من 19 وثلث
مليار دولار لتصل الى 17 مليار دولار
بنسبه انخفاض بلغت
12% وفي المجال التعليمي انخفض عدد طلاب
الجامعات الخاصه بنسبه وصلت الى
25% نتيجه تراجع دخل ذووهم وفي الجانب
الصحي اغلقت
29% من المستشفيات الخاصه اي حوالي 400
مستشفى كما انخفض عدد الوحدات الصحيه
العامه والخاصه وبشان حوادث القطارات
ارتفعت من
447 عام 2012 الى نحو
1130 حادثا عام 2015 بنسبه زياده بلغت
176 في ارقام صادمه عن مشهد مصر خلال
الاعوام الاخيره زاد قتام ته ما كشفه رئيس
الاداره المركزيه للاحصاءات السكانيه بشان
نسبه الفقر حيث اشار الى ان ثلث سكان
البلاد باتوا تحت خط الفقر المدقع بينما
تشير معطيات غير رسميه الى ان الفقر يشمل
نصف سكان البلاد ترد على مستوى جميع
المؤشرات ومناحي الحياه الا الصاديه
والاجتماعيه والصحيه والتعليميه جعل خبراء
يقولون انها اوضاع تتهاوى يوما بعد يوم
رغم ضخامه المساعدات المقدمه لمصر والتي
زادت عن
23 مليار دولار ولم يظهر لها على حياه
المصريين اثر
ملموس ينضم الينا في الاستديو المحلل
الاقتصادي المصري اشرف بدر الدين وعبر
الهاتف من القاهره الخبير الاقتصادي علاء
عبد الحليم مرحبا بكما سيد اشرف بدر الدين
ما اهميه هذا التقرير الصادر من حيث
الارقام التي وردت فيه وايضا الجهه التي
اصدرته بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نحن امام
تقرير رسمي بيفضح اكاذيب السيسي ويبين زيف
ادعاءات حكومه النظام الانقلابي وان مصر
في ظل حكم العسكر تحولت من قد الدنيا الى
شبه دوله الى بلد ضايع كما قال السيسي
وهذا التقرير بيبين ان استمرار النظام
العسكري في مصر يعني مزيد من الجهل
والتخلف والمرض وتدهور حاد في كافه
المجالات والمؤشرات في مصر رغم ان ما حصل
عليه السيسي من اموال معونات وقروض داخليه
وخارجيه تجاوز مجموعها 2800 مليار جنيه
تكفي لسداد ديون مصر وتكفي لاعاده بناء
مصر وتكفي لاعاده مصر الى مصف الدول
المتقدمه لو انها احسن استغلالها ووضعت في
ايد امينه فحينما نرى في مجال التعليم
واضافه الى الارقام التي وردت في التقرير
الانفاق على التعليم في موازنه هذا العام
103 مليار الاستثمارات العامه اللي هي
المباني والمعدات والتجهيزات لا تتجاوز
10% من هذا الانفاق رغم ان هناك نص دستوري
بينص في الماده 19 على ان الانفاق على
التعليم والبحث العلمي يجب ان يكون 7% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لكن الانفاق في
الموازنه الحاليه
3.2% وليت هذا المبلغ تم انفاقه اخر تقرير
صادر عن وزاره الماليه عن اداء الموازنه
خلال السته اشهر الاولى من هذا العام
المالي بيقول ان الاستثمارات العامه ما
انفق عليها 50% من المستهدف فنحن امام
كارثه حقيقيه رغم ان الاموال التي حصل
عليها السيسي احنا عندنا 60,000 مدرسه
ومعهد ديني في مصر الاموال اللي حصل عليها
السيسي كانت تكفي لبناء 350,000 مدرسه
تضاعف يعني عدد المدارس في مصر خمس اضعاف
سيد علاء عبد الحليم يعني هذا التقرير
يدين الحكومه ويوثق الاخفاقات وهو صادر عن
جهه وهي جهه الجهاز المركزي للاحصاء وهي
الجهه رقم واحد في ما كل ما يتعلق
بالارقام
والاحصاءات الرسميه في مصر كيف تنظر الى
مثل هذا
التقرير هو التقرير لا شك ان بيوضع ان في
مشاكل في الاقتصاد المصري لكن في الحقيقه
في بعض الامال في بعض الامور لكن محلوله
مشكله القبض مشكله الكهرباء حلت كويس في
مشاكل تفرت كثيرا بعد جنيه المصري اسعار
المح تثر على التضخم العال
بالتضخم
نعاني
بمشكله في وصول الصوت مع السيد علاء عبد
الحليم سيد علاء
تسمعني حتى يجهز السيد علاء عبد الحليم
حليم من القاهره اذهب الى السيد اشرف بدر
الدين سيد اشرف ما دلاله وخطوره المؤشرات
التي ظهرت بالارقام والتي تتحدث عن تدهور
في قطاعات حيويه ومهمه الاقتصاد الصحه
التعليم المؤشرات الديموغرافيه وايضا
الاجتماعيه كما ذكرنا نحن امام كارثه
حقيقيه يوجهها المواطن المصري لا تتمثل في
الغلاء اللي وصل الى
33.1% كما قال البنك المركزي وهو اعلى
معدل تضخم في مصر منذ الاربعينات منذ اكثر
من 70 سنه في مجال الصحه حينما تغلق 400
مستشفى خاص في عام واحد تمثل 30% من مجموع
المستشفيات الخاصه في مصر وحينما ينخفض
عدد الاسره في القطاع الحكومي بنسبه 5%
وحينما ينخفض اجمالي عدد المستشفيات في
مصر ب 20% خلال عام فنحن امام كارثه
يواجهها القطاع الخص الصحي في مصر وده
يبين ما ذكره التقي ايضا من ازدياد اعداد
الوفيات وخفض معدلات المواليد ايضا سبب
هذا الانخفاض الكبير في الانفاق على مجال
الصحه في الموازنه العامه للدوله ورغم ان
الدستور ايضا ينص على ان الانفاق على
الصحه يجب ان يكون 3% ما ادرك في الموازنه
1.5%
والاستثمارات فيه لا تزيد عن 15% اللي هي
المنشات الجديده والمعدات والتجهيزات
والاجهزه الطبيه وما تم تنفيذه 50% فنحن
امام يعني يعني الواقع والارقام تؤكد اننا
امام كارثه صحيه في مصر ا الضيف في
القاهره بات جاهزا معي كما استمعت اذا
الارقام والمؤشرات تدل على ان مصر تعيش
كارثه حقيقيه في قطاعات عديده كما يرى
الضيف هنا في الاستديو اشرف بدر الدين كيف
تنظر الى مثل هذه الارقام والمعطيات
الصادمه يا سيدتي الفاضل هذا تقرير رسمي
تقرير الرسمي بيعترف ان في مشكله وانه في
مشكله في بنيه الاقتصاد المصري في مشكله
هيكليه وان تفاقمت هذه المشاكل بعد
التعويم الجنيه وتفاقمت بعد زياده اسعار
المحروقات كويس لكن دي مشكله انت بتحاول
تحافظ على استقرار الدوله بتحاول بالتالي
بتزود الانفاق العسكري لان احنا في منطقه
منتهه في الشرق الاوسط سواء مع الجيران ما
يحدث في ليبيا او ما يحدث في صينا هو
حقيقه تاثرت سلبا كثيرا مصر وكانت الاسباب
موضوعيه يعني انخفاض التحويلات المصر في
الخارج او انخفاض السياحه نتيجه ما حدث من
انفجار الطياره الروسيه وتوقف احد
الشارعين المهمه بالنسبه للسياحه المصريه
لكن الامر ليس بهذا السو يعني ربما هناك
في تقرير للاكونت بيتكلم ان الاقتصاد
المصري اقتصاد واح وان هذه كانت جراحه مره
وكانت قرارات صعبه اطرت الحكومه والرئاسه
لاتخاذها لمحاوله تصحيح الوض وان احنا
نتذكر ان قضيه الدعم قضيه هيكليه في
المصري تفاقمت منذ يناير 77 والرئيس
السدات اضطر ساعتها لغاء زياده الاسعار
وتفاقم مشكله الدعم
ولم لم تكن هناك في حلول جوهريه بالنسبه
لهذا الامر وكانت كلها متخنات
لكن بالنسبه لدعم المحروقات وده اظن
الامور كويسه شاهدنا استقرار بالنسبه للك
سيد سيد علاء عبد الحليم يعني هناك تراجع
في قطاعات حيويه وهامه مثل الصحه ومثل
التعليم على سبيل المثال التعليم تراجع
بنسبه تقارب الربع في عدد الطلاب الذين
يرتدون الجامعات وهذا خطير بالنسبه
لمستقبل البلاد
وايضا تخفيض كبير في ميزانيه الصحه وهذه
القطاعات حيويه وانت تتحدث على يعني انفاق
على امور مهمه تعتبرها به اولويات كشق
العسكري والجانب العسكري ولكن اين هي
اهتمامات الحكومه في القطاعات الحيويه
الاخرى هناك في تقصير وهناك في مشاكل
كثيره والحكومه اعترفت بهذه المشاكل وصدور
تقرير من بنك المركزي ان نسبه التضخم
تجاوزت 33% يعني ان هناك اعتراف بالمشكله
ودي بدايه الحل لكن مصر في الحقيقه لديها
مشاكل كثيره مرتبطه
بتوقف جزء كبير من السياحه خصه السياحه
روسيه كان هناك مشاكل نتيجه وجود سعر
للدولار سعر رسمي كان قريب 9 جنيه وسعر
كان موجود في السوق السودا او السوق
الموازيه وبالتالي اثر سلبا على تحويلات
المصر في الخارج انا بظن ان ربما مع تحريك
سعر الجنيه وتعويم كده ان احنا نشاهد
زياده بالنسبه لهذا البنك ويتبقى بس ربما
الامر يحتاج انه الدعم من ولكن ولكن سيد
سيد علاء عبد الحليم يعني مصر هي ان فق
على هذه الجوانب ولكن هناك ايضا اموال
تلقتها مصر 45 مليار دولار تقريبا من قبل
الدول الداعمه بالاضافه الى 25 مليار
دولار قرود للنظام من قبل المؤسسات
الدوليه الرئيسيه ومع ذلك نشهد هذا
التراجع الكبير في هذه القطاعات
الهامه اختلف مع القروض ليس للنظام القروض
لدوله مصر وكانت مصر مهمه وكانت تم فقد
كثير منها
في ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع سواء بالنسبه
للاسطول البحري او بالنسبه للقوه الجويه
نتيجه المشاكل ما يحدث في الشرق الاوسط
لكن في الحقيقه ان الحكومه والبرلمان
محتاجين ان يكون في اهتمام اكثر بالف
الاكثر فقيرا وكانت هناك بعض المحاولات في
مشروع تك مشروع ده لكن لازالت هناك مشاكل
والكل بيعترف انه في مشاكل ولن يستطيع احد
ان ينكر ان هناك مشاكل وان الامر بيحتاج
الى توفير ب افضل الاستثمار من خلال قانون
للاستثمار تزميل المصانع المعطله لكن هناك
مشاكل حقيقيه والكل بيعترف بها سيد اشرف
كيف تنظر هناك اولويات وترتيب ل الاولويات
لدى الحكومه المصريه لترشيد الانفاق في
القطاعات التي ترتقيها رئيسيه يعني هذه
الموازنه العامه للدوله وبتقول ان الانفاق
على القطاع العسكري وهو الباب الخامس من
الموازنه المصروفات الاخرى خلال الاربع
سنوات الماضيه لم يتجاوز 200 مليار جنيه
واحنا بنتكلم عن 20800 مليار جنيه يعني
كان اولى من مشروع قناه السويس اللي بيثبت
التقرير ان ايراداتها انخفض ضت بنسبه 4.5%
وان معدل السفن العابره يوميا متوسط السفن
زاد من 45 ل 47 سفينه فقط مع ان القناه
كانت قبل هذه التفريعه بتستوعب 76 سفينه
يمكن ان تستوعب 76 سفينه يوميا كان اولى
ان توجه هذه الاموال الى هذه الخدمات
الرئيسيه كالتعليم والصحه والنقل
والمواصلات اللي بيقول التقرير ان عدد
التكاتك زاد في مصر من سنه 2014 من 65000
توك توك الى 85000 توك توك هذا معناه تدني
كبير في مستوى خدمه النقل ومعناه زياده
كبيره في معدلات الفقر الى ان تلجا الناس
لانها تصبح سواين تكاتك كيف تصنف هذا
التدهور هل هو من باب الفشل في اداره هذه
القطاعات والصرف على هذه القطاعات ام من
باب الافشات هو فشل وفساد لان لما
الصادرات تقل بنسبه 14% والواردات تزيد 9%
والعجزه الميزان التجاري يزيد بنسبه 22%
معدل النمو اللي كان متوقع ان يزيد انه
يبقى 4.4 بقى 2.2 يعني انخفاض 50% في معدل
النمو المتوقع تحويلات المصريين في الخارج
لما تقل 2.3 من مليار دولار بنسبه 12%
حوادث القطارات اللي تزيد مقارنه بسنه
2012 بنسبه 176 في حوادث السيارات زادت
انتاج الحاصلات الزراعيه حضرتك الزره
الرفيعه انخفضت 11% الرز انخفض 12% انتاجه
الفول انخفض 11% الفواكه انخفضت % ضيفي
اسال ضيفي في ما تبقى من الوقت في القاهره
علاء عبد الحليم سيد علاء عبد الحليم هل
ترى بان هذا التقرير قد يغير شيء في
سياسات
الحكومه لازم يغير شيء ولا لازم يكون في
دور النواب ولازم يكون في ر الحكومه لان
ده تقرير صادم لكن تقرير بيكشف الحقيقه
وان هناك مشاكل حقيقيه لابد ان يواجهها
وان الامر كان هناك انفق كبير في البنيه
الاساسيه وفي وان هذا الامر بياخذ فتره
طويله ليكون لاثر و لكن في الحقيقه في
انتشار زياده بالنسبه للفقر في الطبقه
الوسطى جزء كبير منها نزل الى الطبقه
الفقيره لكن لابد ان يكون هناك في حركه
جاده من الحكومه وم الرئاسه شكرا لك من
القاهره الخبير الاقتصادي علاء عبد الحليم
واشكر ايضا في الاستديو ضيف في المحل
الاقتصادي المصري السيد اشرف بدر الدين
شكرا لكما على المشاركه وبذا نصل الى ختام
الحصاد شكرا على المتابعه الى
اللقاء
y